[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
ERIK DEMAINE: All right,
welcome back to 006.
Today we start a totally
new section of the class.
Up till now, we've
mostly been showing
you really cool and powerful
algorithms, sorting algorithms,
graph algorithms, data
structures, trees, lots
of good stuff that you
can apply to solve tons
of algorithmic problems,
either by reducing to the data
structures that we showed you,
or reducing to graph problems
that we showed you,
or by modifying
those algorithms a bit.
Today we're going to start a new
section on algorithmic design--
how to, from scratch, come
up with a polynomial time
algorithm to solve a problem.
And in particular,
we're going to talk
about a algorithmic
design paradigm called
dynamic programming, which
is extremely powerful.
It's probably the most powerful
algorithmic design paradigm.
Very general.
Can solve lots of problems.
It's a particular type of
recursive algorithm design.
And in general, this class--
all of algorithms-- is about
recursive algorithm design
at some level, because
we want to write
constant-sized pieces
of code that solve
problems of arbitrary size.
We have some problem
size n and we're
trying to write 100 lines
of code or whatever,
some constant amount that
doesn't depend on the problem
size.
We have one
algorithm that solves
all instances of the problem.
And so we have to write code
that is recursive or uses loops
or somehow reuses
the instructions
that we give the computer.
And you may know you can
convert any algorithm based
on loops into an
algorithm using recursion.
And we're going to take
the recursive view today,
in particular
because it fits very
well with our proof-by-induction
technique, which we've
used throughout this class,
but also because it gives us
some structure on how different
subproblems relate in something
called a subproblem graph, that
we'll be talking about today.
And so we're going to start
out with, in general, how do we
design recursive algorithms?
That's sort of the overall,
encompassing everything.
We have thought
very hard to come up
with a cool acronym for this
paradigm which we invented
called SRTBOT--
thanks, Jason.
And so we'll talk-- it's
not actually for sorting.
It's just an acronym for
sub-problems, relations,
topological order, base case,
original problem, and time.
But it's an acronym that
will help you remember
all the steps you need
in order to specify
a recursive algorithm.
And dynamic programming
is going to build
on this template by
adding one new idea called
memoization, which is just
the idea of reusing work
that you've done before.
And that's going to let
us solve tons of problems.
And let's see.
I don't-- let's get into it.
So we'll start out
today with SRTBOT.
So here is SRTBOT
down the column here.
This is a recursive
algorithm design paradigm.
And in general, what
we're going to do
is take the problem that
we actually want to solve
and split it up into lots
of possible sub problems.
And so the first part
is to define what
the heck are the subproblems.
In general, we'll want some
polynomial number of them.
But it's pretty open-ended
what these look like.
And the hardest part,
usually, in defining
a recursive algorithm
is figuring out
what the sub problems should be.
Usually they're related to
the problem you want to solve.
Often the problem
you want to solve--
this is actually
near the last step--
the original problem
you're trying to solve
is often one of
these sub problems.
And then you use the
smaller sub problems
in order to build up the
final, original problem.
But sometimes at
the end, you need
to take a bunch of
subproblems and combine them
into your original problem.
You can think-- one analogy
you can think of here
is divide and
conquer algorithms,
which also had
this kind of style.
But more generally, we're going
to relate different sub problem
solutions with some recursive
structure-- some recurrence
relation.
This is just a
recursive algorithm
that defines how to solve
one problem in terms
of smaller sub-problems
for some notion of smaller.
And this is given by
the topological order.
So if we think of the
subproblems as a graph
and we draw an edge between--
so the vertices of the
graph are sub problems.
The edges are the dependencies
between those subproblems.
Then what we'd like is
the topological ordering,
the topological sort problem
we talked about in the context
of DFS or DAG shortest paths.
What we would like is that the
subproblems and the calls--
the recursive calls between them
in this recursive relation--
forms a DAG.
We want it to be
acyclic, otherwise
you have an infinite loop
in your recursive calls.
If you have a cycle,
you'll never terminate.
And so to make sure
that these dependencies
between subproblems given
by this recurrence relation
is acyclic, one
way to do that is
to specify a topological order.
Or you could prove
it some other way.
But often it's just a for
loop to say, just do it
in this order.
Then of course any recursive
structure needs base cases.
So that's a useful
step not to forget.
We want to solve the original
problem using these sub
problems.
And then we analyze a
running time at the end.
So six easy steps.
Actually, the hardest
ones are these two,
which are interrelated.
And what we're going to see
over the next four lectures--
this is the first
of four lectures
on dynamic programming-- is
lots of examples of applying
this paradigm over and over
together with the memoization
idea, which we'll get to soon.
Let's see an example first of
an algorithm we've already seen,
which is merge sort, so a
divide and conquer algorithm,
phrased with this
structure of SRTBOT.
So for the sub problems--
so our original problem is
to sort the elements of A.
And some sub-problems that we
solve along the way are sorting
different sub-arrays
of A. So for every--
well, not for every i and
j, but for some i and js,
we sort the items from
i up to j minus 1.
So I'm going to define that
subproblem to be s of ij.
So this is something that
I might want to solve.
The original problem
that I want to solve
is s of 0 comma n, where n
is the length of the array.
So that's what I actually
care about in the end.
But we're going to solve that
by writing it recursively
in terms of sorting different
sub-arrays as follows.
This is the recurrence relation.
I've written it
very simply here.
Of course, there's
a merge algorithm,
which is somewhat complicated.
But as we saw the two finger
linear time merge algorithm,
given two sorted arrays--
so this is supposed
to be the sorted array
version of the
items i through m. m
is the middle element
between i and j
and the sorted array of
the items from m up to j.
If we merge those, that
gives us the sorted array
from i up to j.
And that's exactly
what merge sort does.
So in general, this
relation is just
some algorithm for if
you're given the solutions
to some smaller subproblems,
how do I solve the subproblem
that I want to solve?
And so we need to make sure
that this problem is bigger
than the ones that we
recursively call on
and that we don't get
an infinite cyclic loop
of recursions.
And here our valid
topological order
is to say, solve these
problems in order
where j minus i-- the length of
the sub-array-- is increasing.
And then you can check because
m is strictly between i and j.
As long as we're not in a base
case, then we know we can--
these subarrays will be
smaller than this one.
And so this increasing
order gives us
a valid topological order
on all of the problems, all
the subproblems.
We have a base
case, which is if we
don't want to sort anything,
that's the empty array,
or at least in the
original problem.
And then running time is--
I mean, there's no better way
to solve it than the recurrence
that we already
saw how to solve.
So this is just another
way to think of n log n
merge sort in this labeled
framework of SRTBOT.
Let's get to
another problem that
does not fit recursion so well.
But we can make it better.
So this is-- we're
going to start
with a very simple
problem, which
is computing Fibonacci numbers.
It's really just a toy problem
to illustrate a very powerful
idea, which is memoization.
So the problem I'm
interested in is I'm
given a particular number, n.
And I want to compute
the nth Fibonacci number.
And in case you forgot,
the nth Fibonacci number
is given by this recurrence. fn
is fn minus 1 plus fn minus 2
with base case, let's say,
f1 equals f2 equals 1.
And so we'd like
to compute this.
This seems-- this
is a recurrence.
So it seems very
natural to write it
as a recursive algorithm.
So let's try to do it.
We start with what
are the sub problems.
The obvious sub
problems are just
the various Fibonacci numbers,
f i for i between 1 and n.
So there are n of
these sub problems.
Cool.
Let's see.
We want a relation between them.
Well, maybe just to distinguish
the problems from the Fibonacci
numbers, let me write f of i.
This is a function, an
algorithm we're going to define.
And it's defined to be--
the goal we're trying to get
is the ith Fibonacci number
given i.
And then we can write
the recurrence relation
on these guys, just f of
i equals f of i minus 1
plus f of i minus 2.
So in other words, recursively
compute those Fibonacci numbers
then add them together.
That's an algorithm.
Next is t for topological order.
Here, of course, we
just want to compute
these in order of increasing
i from the base case is up.
Another way I like to write
this is as a for loop for i
equals 1 to n.
We will see why.
But this gives an explicit order
to compute these sub problems.
And base case is just the
same as the Fibonacci numbers,
but I guess I should
write in parentheses.
The original problem we
want to solve is f of n.
And the time-- all
right, here's where
things get interesting or bad.
So what is the running time
of this recursive algorithm?
As I've stated it so
far, the running time
is given by a recurrence.
Let's write the recurrence.
So in order to compute
f of n, I recursively
compute f of i minus 1
or f of n minus 1 here.
And I recursively
compute f of n minus 2.
So that will take
t of n minus 2.
This first step will
take t of n minus 1.
And now I need to
solve this recurrence.
This is not a recurrence that
falls to the master method.
It doesn't have a divided by.
So we have to think
about it a little bit.
But we don't have
to think about it
too hard, because
this recurrence is
the same as this
recurrence, which
is the same as this recurrence.
I've written it three times now.
And so the solution to this
is the nth Fibonacci number.
Oh, sorry.
It's a little bit worse
because in addition
to those recursions, I
also spend constant time
to do the addition, maybe
more than constant time.
But if we just count the
number of additions we do,
it will be plus 1 additions.
OK.
But this is bigger than
the nth Fibonacci number.
And if you know anything
about Fibonacci numbers,
they grow exponentially.
They're about golden
ratio to the end.
I'm wearing golden ratio, in
case you forgot the number.
So that's bad, because golden
ratio is bigger than 1.
So this is exponential
growth, as we know, especially
in this time, exponential
growth is bad.
In algorithms,
exponential growth
is bad, because we can only
solve very small problems
with exponential growth.
Very small n.
So this is a terrible way
to compute the nth Fibonacci
number--
exponential bad.
OK, so don't do this.
But there's a very tiny
tweak to this algorithm
that makes it really good,
which is memoization.
And this is a big idea.
It is the big idea of
dynamic programming.
It's a funny word, probably
made up by computer scientists.
Instead of memorization,
it's memoization,
because we're going to write
things down in a memo pad.
It's the idea.
And it's a very
simple idea, which
is just remember and reuse
solutions to sub-problems.
So let's draw the recursion tree
for this recursive algorithm
as we've done it so far.
So at the top, we-- let me
make a little bit of space.
At the top we are
calling f of n.
And then that calls f of n
minus 1 and f of n minus 2.
And it does an addition up here.
And then this calls
f of n minus 2.
And this calls f of n minus 3.
This calls f of n minus 3.
And this calls f of n minus 4.
OK.
And we notice that
this sub problem is
the same as this sub problem.
So to compute f of n minus
1, I need f of minus 3.
And also to compute f of n
minus 2 I need f of n minus 3.
So why are we
computing it twice?
Let's just do it once.
When we solve it, let's write
it in a table somewhere.
And then when we need it again,
we'll just reuse that value.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What about
the f of n minus 2?
ERIK DEMAINE: f of n
minus 2 is also shared.
So let me use a
different symbol.
f of n minus 2 is already here.
So this was at the same level.
But we also get shared reuse
between different levels.
In fact, I wouldn't
even call f of n minus 3
because this whole
part doesn't need
to be computed a second time.
If I already
computed it here, it
doesn't matter which
one comes first.
Let's say this one comes first.
Once this is done, I can write
it down and reuse it over here.
And then in here, we're going
to call f of n minus three.
So there's still another
computation of f of n minus 3.
When that one's done, I won't
need to do this recursively.
OK, so magically
this is going to make
this algorithm efficient
with this very simple tweak.
Let me write down the
tweak more explicitly.
I won't write code here.
But just describe it
as a data structure.
So we're going to maintain our
good friend, the dictionary,
which is abstract data
type or interface.
We could use different
data structures to do it.
But we're going to
map some problems
to their solutions, at least the
ones that we've solved already.
And usually we can do this
with just a direct access
array, though you
could use a hash table.
Just get expected bounce.
So when we write the code
for our recursive function--
so in general, once we have
a sort bot description,
we can turn this into code.
We define f of i.
And it says am I in a base case?
If so, return this.
Otherwise, do this
recursive call.
That's our recursive algorithm.
But we're going to
do a little more now.
And first we're going to
check whether this sub
problem that we're trying to
solve has already been solved.
And if so, we return
that storage solution.
That's the easy case,
but it might not exist.
And then we'll compute
it in the usual way.
So what the code then would
look like to define f of i
is first we check is i
in our data structure.
This is usually called the memo.
So we say, is this sub-problem--
is i in my memo data structure?
If so just return memo of i.
Done.
No recursion necessary.
Otherwise, check
if I'm a base case.
If so, done.
Otherwise, recurse.
So recursively call f of i
minus 1 and f of i minus 2.
And in this
recursion, we can see
that after we call f
of i minus 1, in fact,
it will have already
computed f of i minus 2.
So while this call is
recursive, this one
will immediately terminate
because i minus 2
will already be
in the memo table.
And so if you think about
what happens, in fact,
we'll just have recursion down
the left branch of this thing.
And all the right
branches will be free.
We can just look things
up in the memo table.
So what is the
overall running time?
For Fibonacci, this
should be order n.
Why is it order n?
This is number of additions.
Come back to that in a second.
In general, the way to
analyze an algorithm
like this that uses
memoization is we just
count how many different
sub-problems are there?
Because once we solve
the sub-problem,
we will never solve it again.
That's the whole
idea of a memo table.
So we will solve each
sub-problem at most once.
And so we just need to count,
how much time does it take
to solve every sub-problem?
And here you can
see it's constant.
Either it's a base case
and it takes constant time
or we recursively
call these things.
But those are
different sub-problems.
So we're going to
count those later.
And then the work
that's actually
done by this recurrence
is a single addition.
So in fact, it's n additions.
To compute fn would be
exactly n additions.
So it turns out to be very
nice closed form in this case.
It should be exactly n sub
problems to compute f of n
because we started as dot at 1.
And each one has
one additional--
I guess not the base case.
Maybe n minus 2.
OK.
Definitely order n.
Now, there's this
one subtlety which--
let's forget about dynamic
programming for a moment
and go back to good old
lecture one and two,
talking about the word
ram model of computation.
A question here that usually
doesn't matter in this class.
Usually we assume additions
take constant time.
And we usually do that
because it's usually true.
And in general, our model
is the w bit additions--
where w is our
machine word size--
takes constant time.
But for this problem
and this problem only,
pretty much, for
Fibonacci numbers,
I happen to know
that the Fibonacci
numbers grow exponentially.
So to write them down
actually requires theta n bits
because they are some
constant to the n power.
And so they're
actually really big .
n is probably bigger than w.
Usually you think of problems
that are much bigger than 64
or whatever your word
size happens to be.
We do assume that w
is at least log n.
But n is probably bigger than w.
It might be bigger or smaller.
We don't know.
And in general, to do
an n bit addition--
these are n bit additions--
is going to take ceiling
of n over w time.
So in the end, we will
spend this times n,
because we have to do
that, many of them,
which is n plus n
squared over w time.
So a bit of a
weird running time.
But it's polynomial, whereas
this original recursive
algorithm was exponential here.
Using this one simple
idea of just remembering
the work we've done, suddenly
this exponential time algorithm
becomes polynomial.
Why?
Because we have
few sub problems.
We had n sub problems.
And for each sub problem,
we could write a recurrence
relation that if we already knew
the solutions to smaller sub
problems, we could
compute this bigger
problem very efficiently.
This happened to be constant
time or constant additions.
n over w time.
But as long as
this is polynomial
and this is polynomial,
we're happy,
because we have this nice
formula that the time it takes
is, at most, the sum over all
sub problems of the relation
time.
So I'm referring to sub
problems, like a number of them
and the time it takes
to evaluate this,
ignoring the recursive calls.
That's important.
This is the non recursive part.
In the notes, I call
this non-recursive work.
So this formula gives
us a way to bound
the running time of
one of these algorithms
if we use memoization.
Without memoization,
this is not true,
Fibonacci to exponential time.
But if we add memoization,
we know that we only
solve each sub-problem once.
And so we just need
to see, for each one,
how much did it cost
me to compute it,
assuming all the
recursion work is free,
because that's already taken
into account by the summation.
So in particular, this
summation is at most
the number of sub-problems
times the time per sub-problem,
which in this case was order n.
We could try to apply that
analysis to merge sort,
because after all, this is
also a recursive algorithm.
It happens to not
benefit from memoization.
But we could throw
in memoization.
It wouldn't hurt us.
But if you think about
the call graph here,
which is like s of 0
m, which calls s of m--
0 n over 2 and o of
n over 2n and so on.
It has the same picture,
but there's actually
no common substructure here.
You'll never see a
repeated sub-problem,
because this range is completely
disjoined from this range.
But you could throw
in memoization
and try to analyze
in the same way
and say, well, how many
sub-problems are there?
It looks like there's n choices
for i and not quite n choices
but it's at most n
squared different choices.
In fact, it's the triangular
number sum of i equals 1 to n
of i, different possible
choices for inj.
But this is theta n
squared sub-problems,
which seems not so good.
And then how much time are
we spending per sub problem?
Well, to solve s of
ij, we have to merge
about that many elements.
We know merge takes linear time.
And so this takes theta j
minus i time to evaluate.
And so what we'd like to
do is sum over all the sub
problems of j minus i.
This is the not
triangular number
but the tetrahedral
number, I guess.
And so we end up
that the running time
is, at most, n cubed.
Great.
So it's true that n log n is
less than or equal to n cubed,
but obviously not
terribly useful.
This algorithm by the way we
already know how to analyze it
is, indeed, n log n.
And the running time turns
out to be theta n log n.
So sometimes this equation
is not what you want to use.
But often it's good enough.
And especially if
you just want to get
a polynomial upper
bound, then you
can try to optimize it later.
This will give you
a polynomial upper
bound as long as the number
of sub-problems is polynomial
and the time per
sub-problem is polynomial.
And indeed, n cubed
is polynomial.
It's not a great polynomial,
but this is an alternate way
to analyze merge sort.
Obviously don't do
this for merge sort.
But it illustrates
the technique.
Good so far?
Any questions?
All right.
Let me remember where we are.
Cool.
So the next thing I'd like to do
is show you one more algorithm
that we've already seen in
this class that fits very
nicely into this structure--
arguably is a dynamic program--
and that is DAG shortest paths.
So just to close the loop here,
when I say dynamic programming,
I mean recursion
with memoization.
I mean, we take--
we write a recursive
piece of code,
which is like def
f of some args,
some sub-problem specification.
We check is the problem
in the memo table?
If so, return memo
of sub-problem.
And otherwise check
if it's a base case
and solve it if
it's a base case.
And otherwise, write
the recurrence recurse
via relation.
And set the memo table
of the sub-problem
to be one of those things.
OK, so this is the
generic dynamic program.
And implicitly, I'm writing
Fibonacci in that way.
And all of the dynamic programs
have this implicit structure
where I start with a
memo table which is empty
and I always just check
if I'm in the memo table.
If I am, I return it.
Otherwise I compute according
to this recursive relation
by recursively calling f.
And that's it.
So this is every DP algorithm
is going to have that structure.
And it's just using recursion
and memoization together.
OK, so now let's
apply that technique
to think about the DAG
shortest paths problem.
The problem was,
I give you a DAG.
I give you a source vertex, S--
single source shortest paths.
Compute the shortest path
weight from S to every vertex.
That's the goal of the problem.
And we saw a way to solve
that, which is DAG relaxation.
I'm going to show you a
different way, which turns out
to be basically the same, but
upside down, or flipped left
right, depending which
way you direct your edges.
So what are our sub-problems?
Well, here, actually, they're
kind of spelled out for us.
We want to compute delta
and SV for all these.
So that is size of
these sub-problems.
That turns out to be enough
for this overall problem.
And the original
problem we want to solve
is all of the sub-problems.
We solve all the
sub-problems, we're done.
And then we have--
I think we wrote this at
some point during the DAG
shortest paths lecture--
we have a recursive
relation saying
that the shortest way
to get from s to v
is the minimum of
the shortest path
to get to some vertex u plus the
weight of the edge from u to v.
Why?
Because if we look at a vertex
v, unless we started there,
we came from somewhere.
And so we can consider all
of the possible choices
for the previous vertex u.
And if you start
at s and get to v,
you must go through one of them.
And so this is finding the best
way among all the choices of u.
What's the best way to get to u?
And then take the edge from
u to v for all edges uv.
And this is adjacency minus.
We don't usually think of that.
Usually we look at adjacency
plus the outgoing edges.
This is the incoming edges.
And so u is an incoming--
uv is an incoming edge into v.
OK, if we take that minimum--
and of course, possible
there is no way to get to v.
And so I'll also throw
infinity into the set.
Take the min of that set.
That will give me
the shortest pathway
in an acyclic graph from s to
v. And great, this is recursive.
This was a sub problem.
These are sub problems
which are smaller, I guess.
There's no clear
notion of smaller
here, except we already know
the clear notion of smaller
is the topological
order of our DAG.
Because our graph
is acyclic, we know
it has a topological order.
We know how to
compute it with DFS.
And so that guarantees
there's a topological order
to compute these problems.
And in fact, the
relationship between problems
is exactly the given
graph, G. In order
to compute the shortest
pathway from s to v,
I need to know the
shortest pathway from s
to all of the incoming
vertices to v.
And so this is I guess
in the call graph,
this vertex calls this vertex,
but direct the edge this way
to say that this
vertex requires--
this vertex needs to be
computed before this one.
And so then I can complete
them in a topological order.
OK, we have a base case,
which is delta of ss equals 0.
And the running time is,
again, we can use this formula
and say, let's just sum over
all the sub problems of the non
recursive work in our
recurrence relation
and so it's computing this min.
If I gave you these
deltas for free
and I gave you these weights,
which we know from our weight
data structure, how long does
it take to compute this min?
Well, however many
things there are, however
many numbers we're
minning, which
is the size of the incoming
adjacency list plus 1
for that infinity.
And so if you compute this
sum, sum of incoming edges
to every vertex,
that's all the edges.
So this is v plus e.
So in fact, this algorithm
is morally the same algorithm
as the one that we saw
on the DAG shortest path
lecture, which was compute a
topological order and process
vertices in that order and relax
edges going out from vertices.
So here-- so in
that algorithm, we
would have tried to relax this
edge if there was a better
path to v. And the
first one certainly
is better than infinity.
So the first one
we relax indeed.
The next edge, if this gave
a better path from s to v,
then we would relax that
edge and update the way here
and do the same here.
In the end, we're just computing
this min in the relaxation
algorithm but doing
it step by step.
In the relaxation
algorithm, DAG relaxation,
for each incoming edge to v, we
update d of e if it's better.
And so if you repeatedly
update if you're better,
that ends up computing a min.
OK, so this is
the same algorithm
just kind of flipped backwards.
A funny thing,
although we wrote down
the topological order
of the sub problem graph
here is the
topological order of g,
because the
sub-problem graph is g,
the algorithm doesn't
actually have to compute one.
It's doing it
automatically for free.
If you think about
this algorithm,
generic dp algorithm,
which is check
whether we're in a memo table.
If so, return.
Otherwise, recurse,
or base case.
This actually is a
depth-first search
through the sub-problem graph--
technically through the reverse
of the sub-problem graph.
If I draw an edge--
so from small to big--
so I'm just saying, I orient
the edges from my smaller
sub-problems to the
ones that need it--
then I'm actually depth-first
searching backwards
in this graph because the
bigger problem calls the smaller
problem.
And the memo table is serving as
the "have I visited this vertex
already" check in DFS.
So this is actually
a DFS algorithm.
Plus we're doing some
computation to actually solve
the sub-problems we care about.
So implicit in this
algorithm, we are doing a DFS,
and at the same time, we're
doing this shortest path
computation in the finishing
order of that DFS traversal
because all the
edges are backwards.
This is the same as the
reverse finishing order
if the graph is forwards.
So in the end, we're
computing a topological order
because dynamic
programming includes
in it depth first search.
A lot of words.
But it's kind of cool
that this framework just
solves DAG shortest
paths without much work.
I mean, we did a lot of
work in shortest paths
to prove that this
relation is true.
Once you know it's
true, the algorithm part
is pretty much free.
You just write down
SRTBOT and you're done.
OK.
This brings us to in general--
at this point we have
seen two examples
of dynamic programming.
I guess technically
merge sort you
could think of as
a dynamic program,
but it doesn't actually
reuse anything.
So it's not interesting.
And indeed, that gave
us a really bad bound.
We've definitely seen DAG
shortest paths and Fibonacci
numbers as two
interesting examples.
And what the next remainder of
this lecture and the next three
lectures are going to be about
is more and more examples
of dynamic programming
and how you
can use it to solve
increasingly general problems.
So far, we've just solved an
easy problem and a problem
we already knew how to solve.
Let's go to a new
problem, which is bowling.
Bowling is popular in Boston.
Boston likes to play
candlepin bowling, which
is a bit unusual.
Today we're going to play
an even more unusual bowling
game, one that I made up
based on a bowling game
that Henry [INAUDIBLE]
made up in 1908.
So ancient bowling,
I'll call it,
or I think linear bowling
is what I might call it.
I'll just call it bowling here.
And now I'm going to attempt
to draw a bowling pin.
Not bad.
They might get
progressively worse.
So imagine n identical
bowling pins.
Please pretend
these are identical.
And I have a ball which is
approximately the same size
as a bowling pin.
These bowling pins are
pretty close together.
I should have left
a little gap here.
And you are a
really good bowler.
Now, unfortunately, these
bowling pins are on a line.
And you're bowling from
way down at infinity.
So when you bowl, you
can only hit one pin
or two pins or zero pins.
But probably you want
to hit some pins.
So if you bowl
straight out of pin,
you will just hit that one pin.
And if you bowl in the
middle between two pins,
you will knock down--
that's a ball, sorry--
you will knock down two pins.
And this is your model of
bowling, model of computation.
Now, what makes this interesting
is that the pins have values.
Pin i has value--
this is obviously a toy
problem, though this problem--
this type of bowling
does go back to 1908,
it was also a toy
problem in that setting.
So each of these bowling
pins has some number on it,
let's say 1, 9, 9--
I'll do a slightly more
interesting example,
maybe another one here and a
2 and a 5 and a 5, something
like this.
OK.
Or maybe make it a
little more interesting.
Let's put some negative
numbers on here.
OK.
And the model-- so you're
at the carnival bowling.
Each pin has different--
potentially different values.
And the model is if you hit one
pin, i, then you get vi points.
So that's straight forward.
To make it interesting,
when you hit two pins,
you get the product.
So if I hit two
pins, it's always
i and i plus 1 for some I. You
get vi times vi plus 1 points.
This is the game you're playing.
And it doesn't really matter
that this is a product.
Product is just
some weird function
that's hard to imagine.
If you stare at
this long enough,
you should convince yourself
that the optimal solution
is probably to--
so, for each of these
numbers, I could
leave it singleton or pair
it with its left neighbor
or pair it with
its right neighbor.
But the pairings can't overlap
because once I hit a pin,
it's gone.
It's knocked over.
It disappears.
So because of these nine, which
are a very high value, what
I'd probably like to do is
hit both of them together,
so pair them up,
because 9 times 9 is 81.
That's really big, much better
than hitting them individually
or hitting 9 times
1 or 9 times 2.
1 and 1 is kind of funny,
because it's actually better
to hit them individually.
That will give you two points,
whereas if I'd pair them up,
I only get one point.
2 and minus 5, that seems bad.
Negative 10 points.
My goal is to maximize score.
Do you have to hit all the pins?
Let's say no, you don't
have to hit all the pins.
So I could skip the minus fives.
But in fact, here,
because they're adjacent,
minus 5 times minus 5 is good.
That's 25 points.
So the optimal solution for
this particular instance
are to hit all the
pins, these positive,
these together, these together.
If I added, for example,
another pin of minus 3 here,
I would choose not
to hit that pin.
Good question.
So you just play
until you are tired.
When you decide to stop playing,
how can I maximize your score?
There are many
variations of this game.
All of them-- basically
any variation--
not literally every
variation, but many,
many variations of this problem
can all be solved quickly
with dynamic programming.
But let's solve
this particular one.
OK.
So now we're really in
algorithmic design mode.
We need to think about SRTBOT.
And in particular, we need to
think about what would the sub
problems be here?
And at this point, we
don't have a lot of help.
So I should probably
give you some tools.
If I want to solve
a problem like this,
the input is a
sequence of numbers.
It's a sequenced data structure.
Maybe it's an array of
numbers, which is this v array.
And let's see.
A general tool for
sub-problem design
which will cover most of
the problems-- maybe all
of the problems that
we see in this class
for dynamic programming.
Here's a trick.
If your input is a sequence,
here are some good sub-problems
to consider.
We could do all prefixes.
So let's call the sequence x.
So we could do x prefix means
up to a given i for all i.
We could do all the suffixes,
x from i onward for all i.
Or we could do substrings,
which are the consecutive items
from i to j.
I don't write subsequence here.
Subsequence means you can
omit items in the middle.
So substring you have to
start in some position
and do all the things up to j.
So these are nice, easy to
express in Python notation.
And these are great,
because they're polynomial.
If I have n things--
if the length of my
sequence, x, is n,
then there are n prefixes--
technically n plus 1.
So let's do theta n prefixes.
There are theta n suffixes.
And there are theta
n squared substrings
because there's n-- roughly n
choices for i and j separately.
Sorry?
Sub-sequences.
Good.
Right.
I didn't write sub-sequences,
because in fact, there
are exponentially
many sub sequences.
It's 2 to the n.
For every item, I
could choose it or not.
So I don't want
to parameterize--
I don't want my sub problems to
be sub sequences because that's
guaranteed-- well,
then you're guaranteed
to get an exponential number
of sub-problems, which is bad.
We'd like to balance the numbers
of sub-problems by polynomial.
So these are three natural
ways to get polynomial bounds.
Now, prefixes and suffixes
are obviously better
because there's fewer of them,
linear instead of quadratic.
And usually almost every
problem you encounter,
prefixes and suffixes
are equally good.
It doesn't really matter
which one you choose.
So maybe you'd
like to think of--
well, we'll get to--
just choose whichever is
more comfortable for you.
But sometimes it's not enough.
And we'll have to
go to substrings.
That won't be for
another lecture or two.
Today I claim that
prefixes or suffixes
are enough to solve
the bowling problem.
So what we're going
to do is think about--
I prefer suffixes
usually, because I
like to work from left to right,
from the beginning to the end.
So we're going to think of a
suffix of the bowling pins.
And so what is the
sub-problem on a suffix?
Well, a natural version is just
to solve the original problem,
bowling.
How do I maximize my
score if all I were given
were these pins?
Suppose the pins to the
left of i didn't exist.
How would I maximize my
score on the remaining pins?
Or for this suffix, given these
four pins, what would I do?
And there's some weird
sub problems here.
If I just gave you the last
pin, what would you do?
Nothing.
That's clearly different from
what I would do globally here.
But I claim if I can
solve all suffixes
I can solve my original problem,
because one of the suffixes
is the whole sequence.
So let's do it.
Sort by for bowling.
So here is our dynamic program.
The sub-problems are suffixes.
So I'll write b of i is the
maximum score we could get
possible with our starting--
if we started a game with pins
i, i plus 1, up to n minus 1,
which is a suffix of the pins.
Very important whenever
you write a dynamic program
to define what your
sub-problems are.
Don't just say how
to compute them,
but first say what is the
goal of the sub problem.
This is a common mistake
to forget to state
what you're trying to do.
So now I have defined b of i.
Now, what is the original
thing I'm trying to solve?
You also put in SRTBOT--
you could put the O earlier,
then it actually spells sort.
So why don't I do that for fun.
The original problem we're
trying to solve is b of 0,
because that is all of the pins.
The suffix starting
at 0 is everything.
So if we can solve
that, we're done.
Next is r for relate.
This is the test of, did I
get the sub-problems right,
is whether I can write
a recurrence relation.
So let's try to do it.
We want to compute b of i.
So we have pin i here and
then the remaining pins.
And the big idea here
is to just think about--
the nice thing about
suffixes is if I take off
something from the beginning,
I still have a suffix.
Remember, my goal is to
take this sub-problem, which
is suffix starting
at i, and reduce it
to a smaller sub problem,
which means a smaller suffix.
So I'd like to clip off
one or two items here.
And then the remaining problem
will be one of my sub problems.
I'll be able to recursively call
b of something smaller than i--
or sorry, b of
something larger than i
will be a smaller subsequence
because we're starting later.
OK, so what could I do?
Well, the idea is to
just look at pin i
and think, well, what
could I do to pin i?
I could not hit it
ever with a ball.
I could skip it.
That's one option.
What would be my score then?
Well, if I skip pin i, that
leaves the remaining pins,
which is just a smaller suffix.
So that is b of i plus 1.
I'm going to write
a max out here
because I'd like to
maximize my score.
And one of the options
is, forget about pin i.
Just solve the rest.
Another option is
I throw a ball.
And I exactly hit pin i.
That's one thing I could do.
And it would leave exactly
the same remainder.
So another option is
b of i plus 1 plus vi.
Why would I prefer
this over this?
Well, if vi is negative,
I'd prefer this.
But if vi is positive, I'd
actually prefer this over that.
So you can figure out which
is better, just locally.
But then there's
another thing I can do,
which is maybe I hit this pin
in a pair with some other pin.
Now, there's no pin to
the left of this one.
We're assuming we
only have the suffix.
And so the only other thing
I can do is throw a ball
and hit i together
with i plus 1.
And then I get the product.
Now, what pins remain?
i plus 2 on.
Still a suffix.
So if I remove one or
two items, of course,
I still get a suffix--
in this case, b of i plus 2--
and then the number of
points that I add on
are vi times vi plus 1.
So this is a max
of three things.
So how long does it
take me to compute it?
I claim constant time.
If I don't count
the time it takes
to compute these other
sub problems, which
are smaller because they
are smaller suffixes further
to the right, then
I'm doing a couple
of additions-- product, max.
These are all nice
numbers and I'll
assume that they live
in the w-bit word,
because we're only doing
constant sized products.
That's good.
So this takes constant,
constant non-recursive work.
How many sub problems are?
Well, it's suffixes, so it's a
linear number of sub problems.
And so the time
I'm going to end up
needing is number
of sub problems, n,
times the non-recursive work
I do per sub problem, which
is constant.
And so this is linear time.
Great.
And I didn't finish
SRTBOT, so there's
another t, which is to
make sure that there
is a topological order and
that is in decreasing i order.
Or I might write
that as a for loop--
for i equals n, n minus 1.
This is the order that I
would compute my problems
because the suffix starting
at n is the empty suffix.
The suffix starting at 0,
that's the one I actually
want to compute.
That's the final suffix
I should be computing.
And then we have
a b for base case,
which is that first
case, b of n equals 0,
because there's no pins.
So I don't get any points.
Sad.
OK, so this is it.
We just take these
components, plug them
into this recursive,
memoized algorithm,
and we have a linear
time algorithm.
I want to briefly
mention a different way
you could plug together those
pieces, which is called bottom
up dp, which is--
let's do it for this example.
So if I have--
let's see.
Let me start with the base
case, b of n equals 0.
But now it's an assignment.
And I'm going to do for loop
from the topological order
for i equals n, n minus 1 to 0.
Now I'm going to do the
relation, b of i equals
max of b of i plus 1 and
b of i plus 1 plus bi
and b of i plus 2
plus di vi plus 1.
Technically this only works
if i is strictly less than n
minus 1.
So I should have an if i is less
than minus 1 for that last part
because I can only do--
I can only hit two pins if
there's at least two pins left.
And then return b of 0.
So what I just did
is a transformation
from this SRTBOT template into
a non-recursive algorithm, a
for loop algorithm, where
I wrote my base case first.
Then I did my topological order.
Then I did my relation.
Then at the end, I did my--
not base case.
The original problem.
And provided you can write
your topological order
as some for loops.
This is actually a great way
to write down a dp as code.
If I were going to
implement this algorithm,
I would write it this way,
because this is super fast.
No recursive calls.
Just one for loop.
In fact, this is almost
a trivial algorithm.
It's amazing that this
solves the bowling problem.
It's in some sense considering
every possible strategy I could
for bowling these pins.
What we're using is what we
like to call local brute force,
where when we think
about pin i, we
look at all of the possible
things I could do to pin i,
here there's really only three
options of what I could do.
Now, normally, if I tried
all the options for pin i
and then all the options for i
plus 1 and i plus 2 and so on,
that would be exponential.
It'd be 3 times 3 times 3.
That's bad, but because I
can reuse these sub problems,
it turns out to
only be linear time.
It's almost like magic.
dp-- dp is essentially an idea
of using local brute force.
And by defining a small number
of sub-problems up front--
and as long as I stay
within those sub problems,
as long as I'm always recursing
into this polynomial space,
I end up only doing
polynomial work,
even though I'm in
some sense exploring
exponentially many options.
And it is because
what I do to this pin
doesn't depend too much to
what I do to a pin much later.
There's a lot of intuition
going on here for what--
when DP works.
But we're going to see a
lot more examples of that
coming up.
And I just want to mention
the intuition for how
to write a recurrence
like this is
to think about-- in
the case of suffixes,
you always want to think
about the first item, or maybe
the first couple of items.
The case of prefixes, you always
think about the last item.
And for substrings, it could be
any item-- maybe in the middle.
If I remove an item from
the middle of a substring,
I get two substrings,
so I can recurse.
Here or in general,
what we want to do
is identify some
feature of the solution
that if we knew that
feature we would be done.
We would reduce to a
smaller sub problem.
In this case, we
just say, well, what
are the possible things I
could do to the first pin?
There are three options.
If I knew which option
it was, I would be done.
I could recurse
and do my addition.
Now, I don't know which
thing I want to do.
So I just try them
all and take the max.
And if you're maximizing,
you take the max.
If you're minimizing,
you take the min.
Sometimes you take
an or or an and.
There might be some
combination function.
For optimization
problems where you're
trying to maximize or
minimize something,
like shortest paths
you're trying to minimize,
we put them in here.
So usually it's min or max.
And this is extremely powerful.
All you need to do--
the hard part is this
inspired design part
where you say, what do I
need to know that would
let me solve my problem?
And if you can identify that
and the number of choices
for what you need to
know is polynomial,
then you will be able to get
a polynomial dynamic program.
That's the intuition.
You'll see a lot more examples
in the next three lectures.